les etats unis sont le troisième pays le
plus touché par la pandémie du
coronavirus en nombre de cas avec plus
de 35000 personnes infectées et 4 171
morts selon le dernier bilan de
l'université d'hopkins après avoir
annoncé le test de chloroquine pour
enrayer l'épidémie
donald trump a dévoilé que la garde
nationale allait être déployé dans les
états de new york washington et la
californie les trois plus touchée du
pays
[Musique]
nous voulons gagner la guerre aussi vite
que possible et avec le moins de morts
possibles nous voulons avoir le moins de
décès possibles aujourd'hui j'annonce
des mesures pour aider new york la
californie et washington à faire en
sorte que la garde nationale puisse
répondre efficacement à cette crise en
plus du déploiement de la garde
nationale
le président américain a annoncé la
construction de plusieurs hôpitaux de
campagne
en plus de grandes quantités de matériel
j'ai également demandé à l'agencé
fédérale des situations d'urgence de
fournir ce qui suit quatre grands
hôpitaux fait des roses de campagne
d'une capacité de 1000 lits pour l'état
de new york
huit grands hôpitaux fédéraux de
campagne d'une capacité de 2000 lits
pour la californie et trois grands
hôpitaux fédéraux de campagne ainsi que
quatre petits centres médicaux fédéraux
d'une capacité de 1000 lits pour l'état
de washington
côté économie un plan de relance pour
portant l'injection de 2000 milliards de
dollars dans l'économie américaine a été
présenté au sénat plan qui n'a pas
obtenu d'accord malgré plusieurs jours
de négociations les démocrates estiment
que le projet de loi avait trop de
problèmes la législation de nombreux
problèmes en tête de liste elle comprend
un important plan de sauvetage des
entreprises sans aucune protection pour
les travailleurs et pratiquement aucune
surveillance
le projet de loi était également très
troublant car les hôpitaux les étals
évident les travailleurs médicaux
avaient désespérément besoin d'argent
il s'agit d'une crise de santé publique
il est inexplicable de lésiner sur le
financement pour lutter contre la
pandémie
à l'international les etats-unis ont
proposé une aide humanitaire à l'iran or
refusée par le guide suprême ali
khamenei enfin les tensions se
poursuivent avec la chine
donald trump accuse toujours pékin de ne
pas avoir partagé des informations
cruciales sur la pandémie